how good are you at making decisions how
about when the clock is ticking or even
when you're feeling scared horror games
love forcing you to make decisions under
pressure and their developers love
exploiting every psychological trick in
the book to make those decisions as
difficult as possible nowhere is that
more clear than an interactive horror
titles where making choices under
pressure is the central mechanic like
telltale's The Walking Dead franchise
and supermassive games until dawn and
the Quarry ahead of the release of the
Devil in Me supermassive's latest entry
to its dark pictures Anthology series I
sat down with the game's director Tom
Heaton to break down how supermassive
approaches crafting a horror experience
where every choice you make can have
dire consequences I think with a lot of
horror games they are tied into us to
certain game modes of shooting an
exploration which you're kind of
committed to if you go down that route
but with the Cinematic room it allows
literally to explore anything that
Cinema can explore we can go there as
well so we could do extreme
psychological stuff we can do extreme
interpersonal stuff and ghosts on things
you're afraid of but can't fight those
are all up for grabs because we can
address them cinematically and we've got
a means for doing that the devil in me
follows supermassive's format of movie
style cutscenes interspersed with more
interactive exploration sections these
cutscenes are peppered with Choose Your
Own Adventure style choices some of
which are fairly mundane flirt or keep a
professional distance pay a compliment
or criticize somebody give career advice
or stay quiet and so on each of these
choices subtly diverts the plot changing
the Dynamics of relationships between
characters and potentially opening up or
locking you out of storylines much later
down the line some decisions however are
more critical run or hide fight back or
stay perfectly still if you've ever
watched a horror movie chances are
you've felt like you could make better
choices if you found yourself in these
life for death scenarios and games like
these give you the opportunity to prove
yourself right but across supermassives
games one thing sets them apart from
other horror titles the permanent
consequences of your choices their
characters often played by familiar
faces live and die by the decisions you
make no checkpoints no Second Chances
play one of our games you'll dead that
character is dead there's no reloading
of checkpoint we spend time making sure
the player understands these characters
and roots for them once we build that
that bridge that empathetic bridge to
the character and we give them a bit of
responsibility we give them a binary
Choice the situations come up less
frequently but when they come up there
they're much much more powerful and that
creates a sense of apprehension in the
player because they know in a sense
we're playing for real that death is
absolutely real and characters will
respond to it they'll react to it the
story will continue it makes those
choices come into very sharp Focus the
mechanics of how people make choices is
the subject of Decades of psychological
research analyzing the ways people try
and fail to make decisions from this
research various methods to help you
make the correct decision have been
created you've probably made a list of
pros and cons before or maybe you've
even used the decide model to help you
difficult choices but however good you
think you are at making decisions there
are two things that exert significant
psychological pressure on the
decision-making process time and emotion
it's not easy to make a list of pros and
cons with a ticking clock and as much as
we'd like to believe everyone is capable
of making rational decisions 100 of the
time as human beings we are often a
slave to our emotions particularly fear
fear affects every aspect of our
decision-making process Studies have
suggested that it affects how we make
everything from Financial to political
decisions and that it undermines our
ability to rationally assess risk
clearly within the context of a horror
game you can expect to spend a
significant part of your time with the
game feeling anxious or afraid it's no
surprise then that the most critical
decisions in these games often come at
the end of long tense sequences designed
to get you as worked up as possible
when we're toying with a player and
getting them into the game that was
scared which is what they paid for you
know they paid money to be scared of the
game that's very precious when you've
got them in that state you mustn't break
it we'll Target an area we'll Target a
bit of the game so in the Devil in Me
we've got this very creepy underground
Spa area which has got no electricity
it's all crumbling and the intention is
definitely to have the the player scared
in that area one thing that is that's
vital to do that is to have a sense of a
threat
now a threat might be real or it might
not be it might be imaginary but you
absolutely need it it's very difficult
to scare people at the beach in broad
daylight because there's very little
threat but if you take those people out
into a forest at night then they will
start to perceive a threat their
imaginations work kind of an overdrive
and that's what we want as developers we
want the players imaginations to be
working in overdrive so they so they
have to perceive a threat and in the
horror game the threat is usually fairly
well defined it's a killer or it's a
vampire you know you know it's there so
now you're in this place where there's a
potential threat and then I think the
next thing we do is we create
uncertainty and ambiguity you hear that
if by that you mean the terrifying sound
then no I didn't hear anything door
closing something falling off a shelf
you don't know if you need to associate
that noise with a threat or not so we
we're raising the stakes all the time
we're raising your attention level we're
really trying to trigger something very
Primal but trying to get your fight or
flight response going
like we have a choice on our hands
fight or flight or fight flight freeze
response is a hardwired reaction to
threatening situations that prepares the
body to survive through the stimulation
of our sympathetic nervous system though
it causes several obvious physiological
changes in the body like an increased
heart rate and increased blood flow to
the brain and muscles it has
psychological effects too quickening
your speed of thought and focusing your
attention on perceived threats
controlling your reactions to
fight-or-flight situations is known as
emotional self-regulation and Studies
have suggested effective emotion
regulation can help you make more
rational decisions when faced with
anxiety-inducing situations but in the
context of a horror game where it feels
like there are no good decisions that
may be easier said than done the whole
point about a fight or flight is that
both of those are probably quite good
options and doing nothing is is usually
the worst option you know so if you're
playing a shooter for example shooting
is usually a good outcome of flight is a
last resort but we try and balance that
up very consciously and sometimes with
really you know a really straightforward
choices to the to the player do you want
to run or hide or do nothing do I just
ride this out and see how it goes we're
putting players into a dilemma but
that's really the very end point of the
the first day I think we've got you into
that bear state to to make the that
decision more difficult get those
decisions wrong and you may come face to
face with another staple of
supermassives games a Grizzly death for
one of your favorite characters Goodbye
cruel world the final curtain is calling
and there's no time for an encore
[Music]
though the devil in me's masked
antagonist is inspired by real-life
serial killer H.H Holmes in the world of
the game supermassive also Drew
inspiration from torture horror movies
like the saw franchise creating what
they say is set to be their glorious
game to date I hate looking at court
because then I start to feel seeing it
again so it's it's kind of that in a way
becomes
threat I'm I'm worried about this how
can I avoid this isn't going to spring
on me suddenly the court really triggers
fight or flight very very aggressively
again you mustn't overuse it it's like
we're cooking the player in this first
day we're just getting them on a rolling
boil with fear we mustn't tend to high
because then they'll they'll have a big
point and then they have to have a come
down but we mustn't let them get out of
it we try to sustain it for as long as
possible and I think all contributors to
that is all things the player is worried
about seeing they're very effective for
them
if you're not a horror fan being
confronted with these gory deaths
stress-inducing situations and Razor's
Edge decisions may not sound like a
great idea but as we've covered
previously on Mind Games some studies
suggest that experiencing recreational
fear through horror media has benefits
for developing your skills in emotional
regulation within the context of these
games in particular this makes a lot of
sense it feels like having the
experience of making decisions under the
kinds of pressure these games exert on
us is a very good opportunity to
rehearse your responses to stressful
situations and the choice-based
mechanics make for a much more natural
transition to reality than games which
involve more complex systems of shooting
survival or Resource Management Maybe by
playing these games you're hoping to
train yourself to make better Karma
decisions Under Pressure let's just hope
none of us are ever faced with these
kinds of decisions
I read a great article which said horror
was like self-administering trauma
therapy and I think that's I think
that's true it's about being able to go
to a space and entertain ideas that are
not comfortable I think especially so
for games not only do you experience it
vicariously this horrible idea but you
experience it and you have the
opportunity to see how you would respond
to it horror is about trauma it's about
experiencing things that you're really
really scared of
um and and kind of practicing about how
you would cope with them so I think
that's in in general that's a good thing